behind me is the drew damage repair
instructional unit
basically a big metal box which we flood
it's a mock-up ship so the internal
layout resembles pretty much what you'd
see on the majority of royal navy ships
that are in the fleet today
primarily used for practical damage
control training
[Music]
this is serious kit i am i'm really
we're gonna have to go in we're gonna
have to repair some holes in the side
and i'm a little bit terrified it's just
normal temperature water we're gonna
freeze when we get in there we've got
four sections of the ship split over
three decks
we've got complete control over
water levels smoke and lighting levels
we can control
pipe damage deck and bulkhead splits we
can roll the units up to 15 degrees
either sides of
uprights at a variety of different
speeds to simulate different sea states
so today the beginners are going to be
getting just five degrees of roll which
will seem like a lot to them
instructional staff will be getting the
full 15 degrees
to make it harder
the very first thing the 120 psi breach
and it's pointed at us and the very
first thing we have to do is go you
could feel the pressure from two meters
away just from the air it was chucking
at you behind the water
i didn't quite realize how much you'd
feel it when i went to grab the
wedge bag
first hit zulu one will consist of a
small deck split
um and a large multi-split in the ship's
side so first stage leaks stopping on
both of those will be softwood wedges
that was you
because i tried that and i just could
not find the bridge
no no it was really tricky and the first
time i went down couldn't find it either
i knew it was between your two shoes
yeah could not for the life of me get
the wedge in and all the time i was
trying my best to be buoyant as possible
which is not useful
anyone in the royal navy that is going
to see to serve on a ship will have to
complete training here on the drew
intent being to be able to confidently
enter a flooded compartment
carry out first aid leak stopping be
familiar with the equipment they're
going to be using effect
permanent repairs and remove water from
the compartment
the multi split
you were up there for a long time matt
you got a lot in lots of hammering but
as the water's filling up you can't find
where the holes are yeah water goes
above
where they are and yeah lots of
you rub that through as well i was
pushing yeah
you had to take all the weight of matt
pushing against you did you see the bit
where my foot started yeah inside i
couldn't i couldn't bring it back into
the
head of pressure is similar to what you
would see a couple of decks below the
waterline so the water pressure is
we believe to be realistic
some of the pipe damage we do pump the
water in simulate a high-pressure sea
water breach or fluid system
pipe damage
[Applause]
props to thomas are actually splitting a
wedge as well
it won't fit how is it
oh yeah we can do that
[Music]
second hit you're going to see a three
inch rocket hole it's going to be in a
particularly awkward position behind a
locker so we're looking to see somebody
inside the locker possibly with
teammates backing them up while they
look to get wedges into that hole
[Applause]
we've got a safety number on the gantry
watching the exercise and controlling
the exercise they've got complete
control of
the water level within the compartment
so they can
make it they can make it higher if
you're doing well to make it harder for
you or if they're feeling kind they can
drop the water level
they can also remove all the water very
quickly in the event of an emergency
they've got direct communications to the
unit driver who's in the driver's cab
the driver
can turn on and off instance they have
control of all lighting and smoke levels
how much the unit is rolling now it's
clean water similar to a swimming pool
so we chlorinate it um it's stored in a
sump directly below the unit and then we
pump it up to the header tank prior to
an exercise starting
the cupboard
we all tried it yeah i've still got
water in my ear because
just full force i managed to get my head
in and sort of round so that the water's
all here missing my face yeah because
the wedges kept diverting left and right
yeah i was inhaling water most of the
time so even though i had the wedges in
the right place i got exploded back out
of the cupboard because i've got to
breathe but then you then you've got it
yeah eventually how'd you what did you
do to that to make it work which is on
the left-hand side of the incident and
then push them towards the stream and it
was that kind of arrowhead formation so
you put two in
yeah then one in the middle hammer it in
all widened out that's it and because it
was the wedges were given to me in that
formation and then a hammer four lights
like
it worked
[Applause]
we're looking for a second stage build
on the deck split which will just be a
vertical shore
utilizing a rubber steel and timber
sandwich pack on the deck the importance
of damage control training ultimately
flooded compartments will remove
buoyancy and stability from the ship too
many flooded compartments the ship could
be lost
of equal importance there's going to be
equipment in each compartment which
directly affects the fighting
effectiveness of the ship wartime we
need to recover real estate um to allow
us to be able to fight the external
battle
and
peace time
we're looking to maintain enough
buoyancy and stability to keep the ship
afloat
[Music]
control conditions in a simulator it
took four of us five attempts to close a
breach at the back of a locker
but the professionals are in there now
they're gonna do that and beyond in five
minutes took us 20
and that was that was unlike the easiest
levels
[Music]
i've seen royal navy trainees in there
under the wrecking balls and the
trainees you know
it's it's the working together
it's knowing that there is going to be
some because we weren't chaos like there
was teamwork in there we left an entire
hammer behind at one point
but we did manage to do it they trusted
us with hammers and
[Laughter]
[Music]
you